oops
hi I'm Samir and I made a mostly silent
song that made the top 30 on the iTunes
charts so it was a Sunday morning I'm
sitting at Starbucks
I'm think to myself gosh you know what I
hate I hate that every time I plug my
phone into my car the song from Taylor
Swift all you had to do was stay plays
for a lot of people it's Kendrick
Lamar's ADHD or Ed Sheeran's a team or
even Vampire Weekend's a punk there are
a lot more I think those were some of
the more simple ones that they came
across the reason it plays is the way
iPhones are set up is that it plays the
first song alphabetically into your car
so I tell myself I got to do something
about this I can't do this anymore I'm
gonna make a blank song that plays to
give me enough time to go figure out
whatever song that I want to play so I
knew this was a problem because years
before I wrote a BuzzFeed post about it
because at that time a punk by Vampire
Weekend was doing that to me
and I even asked them to change the name
of the song but obviously they didn't do
that so it occurred to me that I gotta
do something about this enough is enough
and I happen to have my laptop have my
phone I'm like I'm gonna do this right
now
I started looking into how do you get
songs into iTunes how does that work so
I figured it out I learned that the way
music it's on to iTunes Spotify Google
Play Store all these places is through a
music distributor so I looked around
found one that seemed to make sense
seemed to be legit seemed to be the one
that people liked so then after that I
looked around to find some mp3 software
I figured I would make it about 20
minutes I recorded the track and then
just through the music software I just
deleted the audio off of it
so I named the song a space a space a
space a very good song first thing that
came to mind I think it was five days
this covered like pretty much most
people's problem and then I named the
album have a wonderful day because I
assumed people would plug their phone in
and see this often so I just wanted to
make it kind of happy it took a few days
to earn it all out figure it out and
then by Wednesday I uploaded it out to
the services and I wanted to charge like
a little bit of money for at $0.99
seemed like that's not crazy for it but
I learned
when you uploaded that long it requires
the person to buy an album $9.99 and of
course that's ridiculous so then I
figured out it needs to be under ten
minutes so I cut it down which if you
actually listen to the whole thing
you'll notice that I say something right
at the very end telling you to change
the track but I think I say it's been 26
minutes and then it's good for you to
change the track I thought I had
uploaded the right version but I guess I
didn't so then I uploaded it to iTunes I
tweeted it out and I was quickly picked
up by one of my friends at fader from
there they've just kind of totally blew
up so many places wrote about it
Lifehacker Mashable realest Popular
Mechanics AV Club BuzzFeed frosted
reviews wired Apple Insider W genius
Cosmo variety NPR today talked about
this new song that is climbing the
charts on iTunes and the reason behind
it it's a little bit unusual people are
buying the silent song that was created
to be the first song to play when you
plug your phone into your car so it's
just kind of like steam rolling from
there and then I went out to dinner and
then Twitter picked it up as a moment
and that's when it just kind of went
like crazy viral so many people quote
tweeting saying you're genius I love
this song is what I've always needed
tagging their friends that have the
problem saying the songs whatever that
they had a problem with it was just like
so crazy it was so much fun next morning
I wake up I think my brother or someone
texted me and told me that your song is
on the iTunes charts I think it got as
high as number 30 so like all day that
next day it's just kind of like going up
and down the charts sometimes later that
day I get a random text from my cousin
and he says you're trending on iTunes
and I went to iTunes and my name was at
the top of that trend Inglis
so while this is happening all these
crazy things are going through my head
and I got a little platinum do I get to
go to the MTV Music Awards radio
stations reached out I did something on
Fox and I thought oh my gosh I'm rich I
could retire life is over but I quickly
realized that that wasn't the case there
seems to be a huge exponential kind of
drop-off and how like the top artists
make money on there and how they not top
ten or whatever seem to make money so
yeah I'm still working it was it wasn't
that much it felt really good it looks
felt really cool to be viral like random
people that I know or see around that I
don't really ever talk to you would be
like hey I saw you on TV I saw your song
random text messages from friends old
family Facebook friends that I don't
really talk to that would tag me in
their post saying my friends Samir
created this song I'd worked at BuzzFeed
before I'd been a part of so many things
going viral but it had never been like
me that was the topic so it was pretty
fun to like to be in the spotlight I
want to say like the full viral in this
craze probably lasted about a week as
far as next steps
maybe there's a music video coming out
yeah I don't know I hope I'm not a
one-hit wonder but we'll see if I don't
know if I come up with something else
would it just be like a black screen I
was thinking of like driving around I
don't know there's so many different
ways that I could maybe shoot a music
video for it
yeah perfect that's got real quick
[Music]